[Música]
a
escala en parís braulio moro
bienvenidos a escala en parís una
emisión de radio france internacional en
colaboración con france24 en español la
toma del poder de kabul por los
talibanes el pasado 15 de agosto seguido
de la imposición de nuevas reglas de
vida apegadas al rigorismo religioso ha
implicado la huida de miles de
científicos y artistas hombres y mujeres
amenazados por la llegada de este grupo
radical a las riendas del gobierno en
afganistán aquí en francia desde hace
cuatro años existe un programa
denominado post pausa cuyo objetivo es
precisamente defender y sostener la
libertad académica de aquellos que han
tenido que huir de su país este programa
es apoyado notablemente y conducido por
el colegio de francia para hablarnos de
la importancia de dicho programa pausa
saludamos aquí en nuestro estudio amaral
esqueixada responsable de comunicación y
abogacía del programa pausa del colegio
de francia bienvenida a mariah muchas
gracias puede venir definirnos
brevemente que es este programa de post
el programa pose es un programa de
sólida solidaridad internacional
científica y cultural
de manera concreta proporcionamos apoyo
financiero a las instituciones de
enseñanza superior e investigación y así
como las instituciones culturales para
que puedan acoger a sus colegas
científicos y artistas que están en
peligro de sus propios países y se ven
obligado a exiliarse de manera urgente
no y yo quisiera simplemente recordar la
importancia de la existencia del colegio
de francia es una institución creada en
1530 tiene ya ni más ni menos que 491
años de existencia y es una institución
única en el mundo pues permite sin duda
alguna promover la investigación de la
manera más abierta posible al mismo
tiempo que también enseña a todos
aquellos que llegan a dicha institución
es sobre la base de esa filosofía que se
apoya el programa bus
el programa pos nació de la movilización
de la enseñanza superior e investigación
francesa tras la decapitación del
director del sitio arqueológico de
palmira en silla por el estado por parte
del estado islámico y eso realmente tuvo
el efecto de una verdadera sacudida no
bueno tras nacido en ese contexto de la
crisis siria llegó otra crisis la de los
universitarios de turquía que se
enfrentaron a purgas masivas
tras el intento de golpe de estado de
2015 no bueno y el programa pues ahora
es una verdadera cartografía no de las
crisis políticas o geopolíticas en el
mundo
bueno desde su creación en
2017 el colegio de fonz colegio de
francia lo ha cogido y lo apoya desde el
principio y claro eso se inscribe en
consonancia con a través una larga
tradición no de apertura y de libertad
académica a marjorie si usted nos daba
algunos ejemplos de cómo se hizo este
programa en apenas cuatro años de
existencia pausa ha recibido ya a 253
científicos procedentes de 27 países
pero la situación se ha cambiado ha
cambiado radicalmente en este 2021
cuando precisamente a causa de la
llegada de los talibanes afganistán pues
esto ha precipitado la huida decíamos de
miles de hombres y mujeres científicos y
artistas como están recibiendo a esta
gente ustedes que han hecho para poder
recibir esta ola de inmigrantes
inesperados y bueno hay que decir que el
programa pues ya acogía a científicos e
investigadores
afganos ya no pero claro desde la toma
del poder por la toma del poder perdón
por los talibanes hemos recibido
gran gran número de solicitudes por
parte de artistas y investigadores
afganos
y en este momento estamos acompañando 40
científicos
mujeres y hombres
y
20 para 20 de ellos ya hemos podido
asegurar una institución de acogida en
concreto pous pausa da dos tipos de
ayuda no por un lado la ayuda financiera
evidentemente y por claro también ayudan
a los científicos en lo que son los
trámites administrativos de poderse
instalar usted es una ayuda fundamental
usted me habla que han recibido ya
varias decenas de hombres y mujeres
hasta el 2020 eran 55 por ciento hombres
45 por ciento mujeres de científicos que
han sido ayudados a nivel internacional
en el caso concreto de afganistán
cuántos hombres cuántas mujeres y usted
tiene el dato sí bueno el claro el post
acoge tantas tantas mujeres como hombres
pero en el caso de afganistán
dentro de los 40 científicos que estamos
acompañando 10 son mujeres y estas
cifras en realidad refleja
la realidad del acceso a la enseñanza
superior en un reciente informe de la
unesco
a
55.000 perdón habían cinco mil mujeres
en la enseñanza superior en 2001 y llegó
a 90.000 en 2018 pero para un país con
una población de más o menos 38 millones
de gran golfos entonces claro es una
cifra bastante débil amarilis usted me
hablas decíamos son 27 países de
bienvenidos científicos en estos 4 años
de existencia del programa para vos
cuáles son los países dijéramos origen
precisamente de estos flujos migratorios
obligados insisto son científicos o
artistas que huyen para salvar su vida
para salvar su investigación a mentes y
bueno la mayoría son originarios de
oriente medio turquía siria irak y male
palestina pero progresivamente hemos
empezado a costar científicos de
áfrica del norte y subsahariana de asia
de europa del este y también en américa
latina
a este respecto precisamente avanzó
usted la pregunta cuántos científicos
han recibido de qué países de américa
latina en donde se ven hoy en día
amenazados y científicos en ese
continente bueno la mayoría claro vienen
de venezuela ya que el país está
enfrentado a una crisis
ya que ahora es una crisis humanitaria
generalizada y bueno también de brasil
tras la elección de bolsonaro pero
también de chile
nicaragua y haití de aumento son
restricciones de carácter administrativo
son gente que se ve amenazada como puede
suceder en el caso de afganistán qué
sucede cuando estos científicos
latinoamericanos es un problema sino
simplemente financiero el entorno no en
realidad son son objeto de persecuciones
políticas no en razón de
del contenido de sus investigaciones o
porque tienen un compromiso político y
son figuras en la esfera pública
amarilis el programa post está dijéramos
dirigido por el colegio de francia pero
detrás de ello hay cuatro ministerios
franceses hay diez instituciones de
investigación
además están fondos de la unión europea
hay ayuda de los eeuu no ha de ser muy
fácil administrar todo un mostró como
éste no sé un poquito complejo pero
bueno hay que mencionar que el
financiamiento europeo ya se ha
terminado y entonces de hecho estábamos
entrando en una fase de
poder de búsqueda de fondos claro porque
nos falta la mitad de nuestro
presupuesto para poder mantener nuestras
capacidades de acogida a cuánto asciende
ese presupuesto dado los números
decrecientes de científicos que ustedes
deben declaró el ministerio de la
enseñanza la enseñanza perdón superior
investigación francés
nos ha otorgado un
financiamiento de dos millones y medio
de euros lo que es una ayuda muy
presencia pero nos falta dos millones
más
una suma bastante considerable de
ustedes para nuestro público darnos dos
ejemplos precisos de cuál es el
recorrido de gente que ha llegado a pues
cómo se les ayuda en cómo desemboca esta
preciosa ayuda sí bueno hay que claro
mencionar que hemos acogido más de
280 personas no entonces habría muchos
ejemplos
ya que más encima en la mitad de ellos
han podido lograr un empleo después del
apoyo del del programa en francia o en
el extranjero pero bueno les podemos
contar en el ejemplo de un parque de
arqueólogos sirio que hemos acogido
durante dos años y medio
durante este tiempo el supo aprovechar
para crear vínculos con redes de
investigación internacionales y es así
que describió la existencia de
materiales arqueológicos
de la ciudad de hama en una de las más
antiguas ciudades de siria y que nunca
había sido estudiado y que estaba
conservado en el museo nacional de
arqueología de dinamarca desde los años
1949 y bueno y eso dio lugar a su nuevo
proyecto de investigación que está
llevando a cabo desde dinamarca pero en
colaboración con su institución de
acogida luna 7 del mundo lewis y del
mundo
cuya experiencia especialista
especializada en el estudio de
materiales arqueológicos es valorizada
integra solamente dentro de este
proyecto entonces yo creo que es un buen
ejemplo del beneficio mutuo entre los
investigadores en el exilio y las
instituciones de acogida que toman lugar
dentro del programa pues
justamente el informe de actividades
2020 del programa push dice que
asistimos a un avance del oscurantismo y
amenazas en muchos países a la libertad
de investigación y difusión de ideas y
me permito citar
dice apunta que miles de universitarios
son blancos de poderes autoritarios y de
grupos oscurantistas son perseguidos y a
veces asesinados más aún cifras del
índice de libertad académica divulgadas
por global publishing institute asegura
que el 80 por ciento de la población
mundial vive en zonas donde las
libertades académicas están amenazadas
es una cifra aterradora simplemente se
éstas son muy preocupantes
en realidad destacan la importancia de
defender a la libertad académica y en
los investigadores amenazados a nivel
nacional como internacional
hay que mencionar que este trabajo de
producción de datos no sobre los ataques
a las libertades académicas a los
investigadores es una herramienta muy
valiosa para nosotros para llevar a cabo
nuestra acción de sensibilización acerca
de los responsables públicos como de la
sociedad civil en general hemos hablado
mucho de los científicos muy brevemente
porque el tiempo se nos agota y también
reciben ustedes artistas si hace poco el
programa se abrió a la acogida de
artistas en el exilio y ahora te el 12
de artistas reciben el apoyo del
programa y se van presentando nuevas
solicitudes sobre todo de artistas
órganos y órganos
finalmente en un contexto donde vemos
que hay un ascenso de la xenofobia
delante inmigrante cómo hacer para
recibir a esta gente que necesariamente
cuando usted dice se ven obligados a
exiliarse para poder ejercer su
profesión
bueno el resurgimiento de ideologías de
extrema derecha y la difusión no de
de discursos de odio es muy preocupante
y bueno en este sentido el programa post
trata de contribuir al cambio de
representaciones sobre los migrantes y
las migraciones
acerca de las esferas políticas pero
también acerca de la opinión pública y
yo creo que
frente a discursos xenófobos y racistas
anti migrantes que buscan
enfrentarnos los unos a los otros yo
creo que con el programa la experiencia
del programa post podemos mostrar y
queremos mostrar que otras historias
puyo negativos hay alternativas claro
pues estamos llegando ya al final de
este escala en parís no me queda sino
agradecerle amarilis que se haga
responsable de comunicación y abogacía
del programa pos su presencia en
nuestros estudios gracias a ustedes les
damos una nueva cita aquí la próxima
semana en otra escala en parís
[Música]
[Aplausos]